PROFESSOR: So I
want to demystify
a little of this equation.
We sometimes use
the basis to show
everything that is happening.
So we have a good basis.
So let's look at it.
So how does it all look
in an orthonormal basis?
So which basis?
Well, you have one.
H 0 was supposed to be known.
So we'll call these states n.
These are the
eigenstates of H 0.
We'll have E n.
We could put a zero.
We used to have that zero there.
But since we're
never going to try
to solve this equation in a
different way, as time goes on,
the time-dependent
system, I said to you,
doesn't have energy eigenstates.
So perturbation
theory is not going
to be about perturbing
these energies.
So I will erase.
E n, and there will
be no confusion.
That's never going to change.
Now I'm going to
write an equation that
may seem a little strange.
We want to solve for this psi ~.
So let's write an
ansatz for psi ~ of t.
It's going to be the
following, sum over n C n n.
If C ns are constants, this
is definitely not right.
This state must have
some time-dependence.
So at least, I should put
a time-dependence here.
But even that sounds a
little wrong, a priori.
You knew that in
time-independent problems,
you can always write a state as
a superposition of your energy
eigenstate.
So now, this is the
interacting picture
we have not any more energy
eigenstates in any sense.
Can I write this?
Does this make sense still?
Well, the answer
is yes, you can.
And the reason is
that whatever you
can say about this
energy eigenstate,
they apply for early times.
They apply for late times.
They anyway exist.
They're a basis.
And what I said,
they are a basis.
So any wave function can be
written in terms of them.
So if I look psi ~
at time 1 second,
I should be able to find
numbers that make this possible.
And if I look at
it at 2 seconds,
I will find another set of
numbers and make it possible.
So by the fact that I've
included here a time-dependence
for the coefficients, it
is possible to write this.
These coefficients change
in time in strange ways,
but that's our unknown.
If I knew how they
change in time,
I would have solved the problem.
I don't know how
the change in time.
But in general, we will try
to find for this coefficient.
So if you have psi ~, you
know at the end of the day,
your goal is psi of t.
So what is psi of t?
Psi of t, from this
blackboard, is the action
of this operator on psi ~.
That operator moves through the
constants and through the sum.
And with the end states
eigenstates of H 0,
this just gives me minus
I E n t over H bar n.
And this expansion should
make you feel good.
You say, OK, here it is.
These are my states in my
time-dependent we function,
let's say.
And it's given by this formula.
If I didn't have a delta H, we
know that without a delta H,
psi ~ is constant.
So they C ns would be constant
if there is no delta H.
And if the C ns are
constant and there's
no delta H, that's exactly
how energy eigenstates evolve
in time.
They are evolving
with exponentials
of the action of each 0.
So this is consistent
with all you know.
If delta H turns on,
the C ns are going
to acquire time-dependence.
And we will know what
the state is doing.
So this is good.
So let's plug, into
the new Schrodinger
equation, this expansion.
And this is our new
Schrodinger equation.
So what do we get?
I get I H bar d/dt of this.
I'll write it here with a sum.
I'll change to letter m.
I'll use dots.
C m of t dot.
For time derivative,
we'll many time use dots.
So I'm taking the time
derivative of psi ~
as in the Schrodinger equation.
I go here, C m m.
And this is supposed
to be equal to delta H
~ times this same state.
So it's going to be sum
over n C n of t delta H ~ n.
So this is the Schrodinger
equation for this state.
We're now looking at
the Schrodinger equation
in a basis, because that may
be a good way to solve it.
Well, one way to
solve it is to do,
in the right-hand
side, a complete set,
introduce a complete
set of states.
So I'll put a sum over
m m m and this whole sum
over n C n of t delta H n.
So this will be
equal to sum over m.
The m is here.
And sum over n, the bra
can go all the way in.
And you write C n
of t m delta H n.
So this is our Schrodinger
equation still.
And now it's kind of in a
nice way in which we have
similar letters on both sides.
A little bit of notation.
I'll call this delta H ~ m n.
We've done that in perturbation
theory many, many times.
So what is our equation?
Well, compare terms with
equal value of the function
in front of the state m.
So we gave I H bar
C m dot of t is
equal to the sum over n C
n or delta H m n C n of t.
That's it.
It's a nice looking equation.
There's a couple sets of
differential equations
for an infinite set of functions
in which the derivatives are
obtained in terms of the
Hamiltonian matrix elements
for the transition Hamiltonian
for the perturbation
times these functions there.
A little more notation
here in the sense
of just understanding the
structure of that matrix
element.
That's useful, because in
practice, all the tilde things,
at the end of the day,
we don't want them.
We want the original ones,
things without tilde.
And we always look for them.
So what is this matrix element
delta H m n ~ is m delta H ~ n.
But remember what delta H ~ was.
You have it here.
So we have m E to the I
H 0 t over H bar delta H
E to the minus I H
0 t over H bar n.
That's no problem.
Everything is good here,
because those are eigenstates.
So we know how much
you get by letting
this act on that state and
that other exponential act
on this state on the right.
So what do we get?
E to the I e m t over H bar.
And from the other one, E
n t over H bar like this.
The two exponential
give you that.
And then you have just delta
H, your original perturbation,
between states of
the Hamiltonian.
I'll write it this way.
Delta H mn, just without the
tilde, which is m delta H n.
Most people call this
the frequency m n.
E over H bar is a frequency.
So the harmonic
oscillator reminds you
of that, E equal H bar omega.
And for easier writing,
you write an omega mn.
So this becomes E to the I
omega mn t times delta H mn.
So this is kind of
a nice notation.
So this matrix elements there--
well, I'll write again the
equation I H bar C m dot of t
would be the sum over n of E to
the I omega mn t delta H mn C
n of t.
That same equation
has been rewritten
in the viewpoint of this,
where we simplified the tilde.
And we can refer everything
to our original basis.
So in a sense, I think this
should demystify things.
What's the situation?
What has happened is
that if you have a basis,
you write an ansatz for the
wave function of this form.
And the coefficients are
solutions of those differential
equations.
So we've translated the
problem to something doable.
If you have lots of
resources, a computer,
and you solve coupled
time-dependent differential
equations first order.
There this are not
partricularly--
well, it all depends
how difficult
is the time-dependence here.
The exponential is not bad.
This?
Well, it all depends.
But this can be
solved numerically.
It can be solved
with many methods.
This has made the
problem concrete.
And we're going to try to
understand how to solve it
in cases of interest.